[Music]
hi Steph hi thank you for coming on into
Canada pride thank you I'm so happy to
be here I'm happy you're here I think a
lot of people probably already know your
story but for maybe people watching this
right now on 80 Canada pride you are a
youtuber a creator and activist sounds
right
is that fair to sum it all right there
yeah I definitely prioritized for me the
creative aspect and I think the activism
stuff just kind of happens but I'm okay
with that yeah I mean you were starting
to post early days you know makeup
tutorials and those types of things and
then you posted a video about
Waardenburg syndrome which really found
an audience and struck a chord with so
many people I'm just here to explain to
you why my face looks so unique I know
it does I'm not stupid
but unique is not synonymous with bad
were you expecting that when you put
that out I was not expecting that I
actually wrote like a very vague script
for that video and maybe ten minutes it
was just I was so used to getting
questions about the way I left and about
my hair and the you know the distance of
my eyes and things that I just wanted to
answer all those questions in the
convenient place I thought I was just
being informative but it turns out the
video had a lot more impact than I
expected not only for me but for other
people as well so I'm very grateful that
I got that it did have a huge impact and
for people who don't know if you could
sum up Waardenburg syndrome what exactly
is that
well Waardenburg syndrome is a genetic
trait that i've inherited from my mom
that for me what it affects is my facial
structure so for me it's the distance
between my eyes some other things like
the shape of my nose and lips and the
color of my eyes and it's my hair the
white hair is actually natural from
birth and I have some patches of darker
skin on my body too and then it also
causes me to be deaf in my left ear some
people are completely deaf some people
have no deafness
and that's that's pretty much the broad
strips if you were bullied for this yeah
and the fact that you were able to put
out a video - you know just it was so
powerful to kind of take that power back
in your hand yeah put that out how did
it feel to get that response oh it was
great I what I was making it I wasn't
conscious about like you know having a
reclaiming my power moment but in
hindsight I really understand that's
what it was and beyond that you're also
a trans activist which is so important
and what I realize what you're doing and
I'm sure probably you realize too is
you're a teacher essentially I had this
conversation yesterday actually yeah oh
yeah I find a default to a teaching kind
of mode a lot and it's not always ideal
but it's my instinct I mean I knew that
when I started understanding what
transness was and I was looking for
information I knew YouTube was the place
where I found a lot of it and my natural
inclination was when I started to
transition to kind of give back and to
share what I was going through so other
people could learn from me like I
learned from them but I don't think I
understood how far it would go
for me and how much it would become my
life it's insane like this has become a
full-time career 100% it's become bigger
than YouTube for me when I started I was
like 12 years old in my bedroom and
YouTube nobody had a youtube career it
was just a hobby and people like to
share videos and I you know it's been
over ten years now and I really it
didn't become a career for me until
maybe four years ago and it's absolutely
not what I expected I didn't go into it
thinking I'm gonna build a career out of
this I want to be an entertainment I
just I wanted to make videos and it just
naturally snowballed into all different
kinds of things yeah it's like a hot
Biak saying yeah what are your buns you
call your fans by little by little funds
what are your little buns mean to you
well
when I first started transitioning I
knew and even before that I knew that a
lot of queer people especially trans
people had a lot of family trouble a lot
of them didn't have a supportive family
and a lot of them even have become you
know disowned after they come out right
and I wanted to provide a something that
they could belong to and that's
something that I received growing up
through musicians and entertainers and I
thought okay if I can provide that
somehow I'm going to I didn't really
understand how large-scale it would
become but I wanted to give people
something to belong to and some kind of
maternal place there's the maternal
feeling and I'm glad I could I could do
that yeah I mean there was that saying
and I've said it before here on the show
they as queer people sometimes we have
to find our family yes I love when you
do the videos where you go back and look
at some of your older videos is that fun
for you to go back to that place it used
to be
now I've had different experiences and
now when I go back to look at older
videos it's not older videos before I
transitioned it's usually older videos
about a year into my transition and it's
not so much that I'm looking to compare
gender but I know I've definitely
changed a lot since then and I I like to
reflect on how I've changed and grown so
that I can make sure I'm growing in the
right direction if that makes sense so
it's at this point it feels almost like
self-care speaking of self-care you took
a break from YouTube for a while and I
know you got some treatment I was worn
down shoe the most basic form of myself
where I didn't have my success I didn't
have my viewers I didn't have my videos
I didn't have my Instagram followers
that environment was just me nothing
else what did that break do for you and
how are you feeling that I feel
incredible I feel healthy for the first
time in my adult life I feel healthy I
didn't realize how sick I was basically
what I realized was I had to take a
break because I was diagnosed with a
very severe eating disorder and I had to
take care of that because until I
interrupted that behavior I could not
improve my circumstances I couldn't fix
anything that I'd done wrong I really I
had to get out of
that cycle before I could correct
anything or you know fix my direction so
I took that two or three months break
from me to you I went to the hospital I
did a full treatment program I have no
shame in admitting that it's the best
thing I ever did for myself yeah I think
if anybody's thinking that they need
that kind of help that they should
absolutely pursue it because it is the
best thing I've ever done there is no
shame in getting no this idea that
self-care is not just looking at
yourself in the mirror and thinking you
look good
I think self-care goes a lot further
than that I think it's more about self
compassion I think it's about treating
your ailments instead of pushing through
I think it's about eating breakfast
instead of chugging iced coffee I think
it's about taking care of yourself on
every level and I think that's something
that a lot of us forget to do especially
in a space and I think that the queer
space can be so focused on looks and
appearance and how snatched you are and
all this stuff and I think it's really
important that we start to understand
that we need to take care of herself too
you know what I love also about your
videos is that you are always you know
listen there they're fun they're upbeat
but you're always educating people and
you're always 100% real I try my best to
be even you know I know that there were
times when I was especially when I was
very sick yeah when I look at those
videos and I can see how I was and I can
tell that I wasn't really being my best
self yeah at that moment I was still
being real even if it wasn't you know
true to me because that was that was the
way I was dealing with it um so yeah
real all the time for better or for
worse right exactly you're gonna have a
digital diary like it's pretty
incredible like 30 years from now you're
gonna be able to go back and look at all
these moments in your life yeah I
actually think about that a lot and and
what I'm creating some of my more
exciting content I like to remember that
when I'm creating it so I try to kind of
try to lead with you know I'm I'm
creating I'm creating a memory and the
memory of course is in my mind but I'm
creating something to remind me of that
moment and I want to make sure that the
video communicates feeling and not just
information
and that's something that I try to keep
at the front of my mind now we're
representation is so important right now
do you feel it has gotten better I think
it's gotten more diverse which is great
I think that for the most part is better
I think there are some small small
groups within the queer community of you
know under under each letter that
prioritize survival in a very different
way I think it's unfortunate that there
is some aggression towards progress if
you know what I mean yeah and I think
that's something that over time will
ease and I think it is important to see
people you know learn and grow even if
it is painful or difficult or if they
lash out at the beginning I think it's
still good to see that growth and I hope
that they do experience that growth
I loved the Rimmel London campaign I
will not fail your words I want a
hideaway I will not change you or lose
my self-respect I will not be defeated
[Music]
actually I don't know how much I'm
allowed to say this but I'll beg
forgiveness not permission I have
another campaign coming out with them in
October amazing and it's gonna be a lot
more like my face is supposed to be in
the stores and that to me is even
greater because I had the posters in the
city which was one thing but being in
the stores with the people that you know
in the positions that I used to be in I
hope maybe I can encourage them to
pursue whatever they want to pursue
whether that's within this industry or
another